arkansas senator tom cotton senator good
to have you
i never anticipated senator that
this country that was energy independent
just a little over a year ago
would find itself
adopting insane green new deal socialist
policies that result in america take
buying oil from russia
uh begging the iranian muellers for a
deal so we can buy their oil begging
venezuela and begging opec i don't know
maybe i'm old-fashioned um i don't think
we should be enriching america's enemies
your thoughts
yeah sean it's crazy joe biden has
shackled our oil and gas industry for
the last year he would rather as you say
go hat in hand and beg the ayatollahs to
pump more oil for us or go to venezuela
to a strongman nicholas maduro who we
don't even recognize as a legitimate
head of their government and sean the
war in ukraine is actually closely
connected to this terrible nuclear deal
in iran as you said joe biden's been
counting on vladimir putin to be his
lawyer for the last year to try to get
iran to cut a deal with us and that's
one of the reasons why he was so weak
over the last year is he didn't want to
do anything to offend vladimir putin and
upset the applecart with this nuclear
deal with iran and now as they were just
about to strike another terrible deal
iran and russia walk away from the table
because they know they have joe biden
over the barrel that he desperately
wants this nuclear deal and they can
extract more concessions from them both
in ukraine and in iran there's a direct
connection between how weak joe biden
has been on iran and the war that
vladimir putin is waging ukraine right
now
weigh in on alberta's premieres and the
statement that if we had finished we
would we would now have finished the
keystone xl pipeline and canada would be
giving us
about around 900 000 barrels of oil a
day canada today said that they can find
ways to give us an additional 400 000
barrels of oil a day
by shipping it through rail etc etc so i
think i'd go to them first rather than
these other countries
why are we doing that
well of course sean but we're not doing
it because joe biden's eco-activists on
the left don't want north american oil
if they have to i guess they'd rather
take it from countries like venezuela or
iran but they are crippling our energy
industry it's not just oil and gas
leases it's permits it's the pipeline
infrastructure it's liquefied natural
gas export facilities all of these
things take time so when you hear joe
biden stand up there and say well the
keystone pipeline wasn't even open yet
that's why it's important that you start
these things now and you do so in a
timely fashion and you build them so
they're available in the future and so
it sends a signal to investors that the
oil and gas industry is a good place to
put your money because it's going to be
stable for years to come instead you
have joe biden and john kerry out there
saying well we need more oil right now
but in five years we don't want any oil
and gas we want you all to drive a sixty
thousand dollar electric car
all right senator cotton great to have
you thank you for being with us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else